When I found you in the wreckage of that ship,
I considered leaving you.
I was afraid you could bring trouble to us.
What do you think they want?
Everything.
We're just farmers.
We're not a threat.
They won't just kill us all.
You're delusional.
You think those soldiers will show their mercy?
Stop.
We’re gonna have to fight.
might stand a chance.
We're searching for soldiers
for a fight against the motherworld
I am a child of war.
I find warriors to fight with us.
I could help you.
A small fee, obviously.
I'm here to make you an offer
You may want to hold on
give you a chance at redemption.
We are beyond redemption.
What about revenge
this isn't just a pursuit of revolution, I have found
the most wanted fugitive in the known universe.
Now it's a new age
for the universe.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my new Rebel Moon trailer video.
Zack Snyder's new sort of Star Wars inspired movie.
He explained some of the origins of the film
to It actually started life as a Star Wars
movie that he didn't change, obviously,
to remove all the Star Wars copyrighted stuff.
you can see a lot of similarities here.
Like it's a bit of Seven Samurai mixed with Battle
Beyond the Stars in his original Star Wars
pitch movie that he was going to make
before he made all of his DC movies.
we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The actual movie is coming at the end of December,
closer to Christmas.
this is just part one of a two part movie.
I think the ideas are trying to create a franchise
like he's got sequels in mind.
There's already a prequel anime that they're making
about a couple of the characters involving like Ray
Fisher's character.
I'll explain that during the video.
part one is called Child of Fire.
It's a reference to Kora because the first movie
is kind of like her origin story.
There are a bunch of flashbacks
with her in the trailer.
Part two is called The Score Giver, which is also
probably a reference to Kora's character as well.
speaking of the name Kora that will remind you
of Avatar The Last Airbender The Legend of Korra.
I did videos for that back in the day.
We just got the live action Netflix, Avatar,
The Last Airbender trailer video.
I did a much bigger breakdown video.
That's what I'll link it down below in the description
that's also coming in February.
So there's like a bunch of big Netflix stuff
they were doing because of Geek Week.
So that's why there's so many Netflix trailers
just in general right now.
Zack Snyder was also really good
about getting really deep on the law in explaining
what's going on during the actual movie.
generally, he's got a couple big franchises
that he's working on at Netflix,
like he's
still making his Army of the Dead sequel movies.
There'll be another one coming out pretty soon.
this Rebel Moon universe of Stories is like the other
big story universities creating so in success.
Like if everything goes well,
I think with these first two movies,
they'll just continue making sequels and spinoffs
as part of this.
The whole idea is, as Sophia Patel is Corey
character used to be
this soldier, like a really high ranking person
inside the Imperial Army.
We're making more Star Wars metaphors here.
yet to imagine This is kind of what his Star Wars
movie might have wound up looking like.
during the flashbacks in the trailer,
you see her referencing being a child of fire.
That's a reference to the actual title of the movie.
At some point during one of their campaigns,
they were forced to commit a bunch of atrocities.
It basically scarred her for life
and she decided to basically leave the empire, live
this quiet, peaceful life on the planet called velt,
which is where the movie picks up.
this is where we get sort of into the Seven
Samurai plot where the Empire is basically
like a David and Goliath scenario where they come
to destroy the planet because of what happens.
As you see during the trailer.
at the beginning of the trailer here, where you see
the imperial ships coming to the town on Velvet,
this is just the empire coming to normally take food
from the planet because it's a member of the Empire.
Like all their different colony worlds
are basically subject to the empire
in that they have to give any kind of resources
the Empire might need.
They're in the middle of fighting campaigns
all over the rest of the known universe,
trying to conquer it slowly.
They need food,
so they're coming to this plant to take some
so the beginning of the movie
they have no idea that this really important person
who used to be part of their army,
Kora is living there.
They're just there randomly to get more food.
in the way that Zack Snyder explained it is that
Kora knows all about the Empire, their tactics,
and she knows that them showing up
is a really bad thing for this town.
But the townspeople have no idea what's going on.
They think that it's good that the empire is.
They like, yeah, the Empire is recognizing us.
and she basically has to catch them up like,
No, no, no, this is very bad that they're here.
They're going to destroy your world.
They're basically going to strip
mining of all of its resources.
it seems like at least at first,
the townspeople don't really believe what
she's talking about
until she decides to leave like she's okay.
Fine.
I'm going to leave this planet
so the Empire won't find me in this scene here
where she stops the imperial soldiers from abusing
this girl is as she's trying to leave the town.
But she stops to save this girl
and sort of sets off the events of the movie.
Zack Snyder also said this scene here
where the townspeople show up and see her
slaughtering these soldiers
is because they're coming to welcome them
like they think it's a good thing that they're here.
they show up and see her
just completely eviscerating them.
so she and the girl basically
catch them up in the empire, winds up finding out
what happened to their men on the plane.
Bus comes as Green's character.
they basically come to wipe the planet off the map.
Thus the David and Goliath references
Zack Snyder was making earlier
having to go around collecting a team
Seven Samurai style to protect the village.
everybody will recognize
Corey Stoll here from the Marvel Ant-Man movies.
I'm not exactly sure
who he's playing in the context of the movie.
He seems just like a normal villager here, like
one of the normal farmers It's green is Admiral Noble.
He's the leader of the Empire's forces on Mother World,
the throne world of the Empire.
They're couple
shots of the throne wall during the trailer
But when the movie picks up,
he's on a special side mission
to find the rebels in this part of the galaxy
who have claimed independence from the empire.
If we're talking about Star Wars metaphors here, it's
basically the leaders of the rebellion.
these people behind him
that look all freaky are called scribes.
They write down the history of the galaxy,
but it's the history as the Empire wants it to seem,
so that they write down the wrong history, like
they don't write down what actually wound up happening.
It's one of those metaphors where like the written
history actually favors the victors.
Like whoever winds up winning these grand battles
is the person who actually records history
as they want it to be recorded.
some of you probably notice
the Dario versus Dario Game of Thrones scene
we have here, like the two versions of Dario
actually facing each other.
if you didn't watch the original Game of Thrones series
when the Dario character
debuted during Game of Thrones
season three ed screen played the character.
but when they got to Game of Thrones season four,
they recast the character with Huisman here.
so for the most part,
especially if you only watched the later
seasons of Game of Thrones,
you just remember him as Dario.
No, Horace within the context of the story,
he's just a regular farmer from Velt.
He didn't use to be part of the Imperial Army
or have any kind of dark past.
He's just like a normal farmer
dedicated to helping his people here at the village
in the way that Zack Snyder explained.
He's kind of like the audience POV character,
the person who has absolutely no skills as a soldier.
Like he's not a fighter or anything like that.
he does sort of
get swept up in the action and doing heroic things,
kind of like the Luke Skywalker character.
When Star Wars picks up.
but unlike Star Wars, he's not, like, secretly
related to anybody really famous inside this universe.
so once the empire learns about what happens,
they're soldiers.
They get ready to come back and force.
Kora takes Gunner to the other colonies
to put this team together.
starting with Charlie Hunnam character
who's called Kai.
He's meant to be like a pilot, a mercenary.
They call him a fixer, quote unquote.
In this universe,
he's like a Han Solo type, like the scoundrel
who winds up helping them in doing good things,
even though he has a bit of a shady past
the Hoyos he's made to have this network of contacts
that they use to help them, he's
probably connected to the rebellion, to it's his shit
that they use to go around collecting everyone else.
Then they go to this planet with the Colosseum,
which is exactly what it looks like,
where they have regular matches.
She ends up finding what seems like a couple
of characters here, most notably Djimon Hounsou
as General Titus, who kind of reminds you of him
during the Gladiator movie.
Very similar situation
there in the context of this movie.
He's another former imperial general
who's like this master tactician who I believe
also grew remorseful about the atrocities
that he committed in the name of the empire,
when Abel then in disgrace,
wound up fighting inside the Coliseum.
So like he was forced to fight in the Coliseum,
the other character
they find in the Coliseum here,
this gladiator arena is called Tamarack.
He's a super capable fighter.
he's meant to be a former member of a noble family.
But after his family had a run in with Mother World,
he wound up owing a life debt
to a rancher for whom
he worked as an indentured servant.
So the idea is when the movie picks up,
he initially refuses
to join the resistance, but then eventually winds up
being convinced to help them.
during the movie, this giant bird creature
that he winds up trying to tame is called the Benu.
Basically, the idea is that it's a wild creature.
He's trying to tame it. It's
kind of like an avatar situation.
this person might seem familiar.
This is Ray Fisher's Darian Bloodaxe.
This woman is his sister in the movie called Deborah.
They're the leaders of the revolutionaries
the way that Zack Snyder explained it.
His sister Deborah does like the actual day to day
leading of the revolution like Monmouth style
they're a bunch of battle scenes
with them to The prequel
anime that they're actually making in the next
couple of years is called The House of Blood,
which is probably going to explain how the rebellion,
the resistance, started with Ray
Fisher's character and his sister
that are probably released sometime around 2025.
They haven't really said This woman with the light
sabers is called Nemesis.
She's just a really experienced sword's woman.
Zack Snyder said the swords are made of molten metal.
I think to avoid the light saber or copyright issues.
So they don't really work like light sabers,
like they're molten metal, they're not energy blades.
that's why the actual physics of the blades
looks a little bit different.
the spider character that you see her fighting
is actually Jenna malone
in heavy makeup, who's worked on a bunch of other
Zack Snyder movies like Batman v Superman.
She's also in one of his upcoming Army of the Dead
sequels, too.
In the movie, her character is named Hamada.
She lives on one of the Imperial mining
worlds called Daggers And they don't really explain
why she gets into this fight with Nemesis.
This robot is Anthony Hopkins in the movie.
His name is Jimmy.
He's like a joke class robot, which is where the Jimmy
name comes from within the context of the story.
He's a former battle robot in the Empire's army
who's been repurposed as a farming robot on belt.
if you're making Star Wars
metaphors, it'd be kind of like a battle droid
being repurposed to a farming droid.
there's a bunch of other scenes in the other trailers,
too, like you see a bunch of the Imperial Royal
family characters.
Carrie always plays the actual emperor For Free
is playing the Regent Belisarius.
I think this younger girl here
might actually be a flashback.
This might be like a young version of Cora.
Not totally sure about this,
But you see him being crowned.
So there might be some Game of Thrones aspect to
what's actually happening on the imperial throne world
with him.
Actually taking power, taking control of the Empire.
Since the movie is coming out
pretty soon, we'll probably get a couple more trailers
with some more footage.
Just explain a little bit more
about what's actually happening during the movie.
like I said, this is just meant to be part one,
explaining most of the origin of these characters
and how the actual fight begins in part
two will wrap up at least this battle,
because they are trying to turn it into a larger
franchise,
they'll probably be some moment
that they end on in part two that will spin up
into something much bigger, early theory
they'll have like their own version
of an Empire Strikes Back kind of ending,
pushing into whatever the next film might be.
there's a bunch of other crazy stuff going on
in the trailer that they haven't explained yet.
So hopefully future footage will just explain
or provide some more context for that.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming out this week,
so make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Click here for my full Loki Season
two Episode six Finale Video
and click here for that other really big Rebel
Moon trailer video with a bunch of different footage.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!